good morning John I'm at the office it's
too early hey Nick and Nicole hi hi
we're doing something weird today
I'm gonna show you just second hello
good how are you doing this is
superintendent Juno she is running for
Congress to represent the state of
Montana you're talking to my brother
right now
oh hi so we do all shooting down here oh
yeah that one's good this is my audience
hi audience and also my brother hi John
I wanted to talk to you and I'm so
grateful for you for doing this
because I don't really want to talk
about policy or about your campaign or
what you're gonna do for Montana when
you're in Washington which I imagine is
most of what you talk about
which is good I just want to talk about
like government being an elected
official you are right now and you know
how things have gotten very partisan and
how that affects you running for office
and you as a person also because I think
often times we forget the politicians or
people but before we get into any of
that I'm gonna give you a pop quiz all
right I think you will know the answers
to all of them though you are running
for US House of Representatives and and
that is a house of Congress so members
of the House of Representatives do what
they make laws and the final question
the pop quiz is how do you expect to
afford the rents in DC um that's gonna
be a tough one probably get roommates
and have to figure out who my friends in
Congress are going to babe we've got all
the questions right this is a girl Oh
awesome thank you so much everyone gets
a good day actually that they've been
doing a lot of work registering voters
and they have a vote go oh I think is it
a live goat there's a life I think if
you vote you get to like pet the guy I
don't know it's just a vote coat that
goes around I've had to draw people over
so then you can register them to vote
now we are on to everyone's favorite
topic which is their own self so we're
going to talk about you so you currently
hold an elected office you are the
superintendent of public instruction
which too is just like the head of
the head weight yeah it's the head of
all the schools in Montana basically
every four years people vote for this
position it's one of our statewide
offices per our state constitution was
your campaign for the statewide office
was that significantly different than
what you're experiencing I'm running for
a more high profile yeah totally you
know the issues are bigger there's more
scrutiny you know there's all there's a
there's a larger microscope on you you
can also get a bigger megaphone and so
that's good too I imagine there's also
tough parts of that like not a lot of
time scheduled for sleep also there's a
lot of people who are gonna be saying
nasty things about there I'm just
curious what the worst part is it is
that I think it's the negativity in
politics right now it's the divisive
this good ideas sometimes don't get to
be discussed because we draw ideological
lines and then talk about you know
fear-based sorts of issues rather than
actually talking about issues that
matter so is it safe to say that during
this campaign you kind of came out so
introduced my partner you have somebody
in your life and they they need to be
there to support you did you feel like
that was something that you needed to do
for political reasons of those personal
ones
yeah I think it was a mixture of both
people expect access they want to know
who their candidates are and I think
stepping up to this level from
superintendent to Congress it was
important to make sure things were out
there because of the negativity that can
sometimes happen and it really hasn't
been become an issue which is it's great
great but I think particularly when we
look at Montana and we you know the
stereotypes around our state and its
people it actually hasn't become a
political issue
yeowch I think speaks volumes for our
state in our country in the direction
we're moving I was on your Twitter
yesterday it says in your bio 54th
generation of Montana which made me
laugh I just want to know how did you
come to that particular number I just
figured it's a long time and you know it
can try to disprove American Indian
people I've Bennett here before America
was a country it's important to bring
that aspect of history to this race as
well if you aren't that tuned in mostly
what you hear about government is the
most dysfunctional face in America we
have very strong local government and
I'm worried about the future in which
young people aren't as interested in
that yeah because they see government as
dysfunctional or because they just see
it as like an unpleasant task to try and
get into that for every message you get
and every letter you get that says I
hate you and you're doing the wrong
thing and you're horrible you get three
or four that are really good or you run
into people where who say my kid would
not have graduated we're not for
graduation matters Montana and yep
you're gonna always get the haters but
you know the good stuff always outweighs
those I believe you I guess yeah you
should what do you think politicians can
do to make it feel like to put the
government like the running of our
country ahead of winning the election be
present 90% of politics is showing up
and you show up where people are
gathered and you listen and you know you
put aside your part of some hat and you
actually listen to people about what are
your issues why are they challenging and
how can we make them better I mean
that's really what the function of
government is to make things better and
and that's why elections matter what
really does matter who sits in those
seats that can actually get down and do
the business of good government how
terrifying is a debate see this I mean
it is something where I mean you kind of
have to guess on what you're going to
get asked it's always a curveball you
never know getting up on that stage it's
something I mean you are definitely
awake last debate actually had an
audience question if you're elected how
will you help LGBTQ people in the
country that sort of was a new question
we had been asked in previous debates
and so my answer was number one get
elected
not fair it's very serious
so I guess my off my last question is
just how do you how do you help
Americans believe in government well I
think number one get elected I mean I'm
not naive about you know there's a lot
that needs to be fixed in government and
we need to really start moving away from
such divisive politics but through my
life and through my role as an elected
official I know good things can happen
it so I do I'm optimistic and I think
most people who run for office they want
to make sure that things get better for
the people that they represent
you're stepping up you're putting
yourself on the line you're opening
yourself up for scrutiny but you're also
opening yourself up to have real
conversations with people and when
you're elected to make a difference to
make a positive difference for the
people who elected you and I think
that's really powerful well thank you
very much yeah thanks is fun John I'll
see you on Tuesday
John there are so many serious arguments
that need to be had so many issues that
need to be discussed that it can
sometimes feel hard to justify just
having a conversation with a person who
was being voted on to be in a public
office as if they are a person but I
think that it's really important to try
and do to imagine these people as people
especially at this moment when the
information silos and the voter die
communication strategies are combining
to create the most extreme partisanship
I've ever seen in my lifetime the result
of all of this is that no one ever talks
about the things that work and so
everybody thinks that everything's
broken but it's not yes things need to
be maintained and we all need to work to
do that maintenance but that doesn't
mean that it's never been worse than
that we're losing and then everything is
crashing down around us Americans humans
we have problems right now but we are
good at taking on problems I obviously
cut a lot out of this interview the full
interview is like a half an hour long I
would love it if you would go watch the
whole thing we got deeper into several
the topics from this video and then
talked about stuff that isn't in this
video at all I thought it was a
fascinating conversation and I hope that
you will as
well you can watch that video here and
click there there's link in the
description and of course as a final
reminder educational videos are exempt
from the time limit so stop talking
about punishments in the comments